la gente en las calles de madrid ya no
está obligada a cubrirse la cara a pesar
del anuncio no todos se sienten seguros
quitándose la mascarilla con la
mascarilla me siento protegida sobre
todo si hay mucha gente voy a seguir
poniéndome la lo que ocurre es que en
espacios en los que haya bueno más o
menos probabilidad de que no pueda
nada evidentemente me la voy a me la voy
a quitar la decisión se tomó cuando la
tasa de infección comí 19 en el país se
redujo a la mitad desde el 17 de enero
pero las mascarillas siguen siendo
obligatorias en los espacios cerrados y
en el transporte público algunos se
alegraron por el cambio de la norma
liberado es agradable porque la mayoría
de las veces que salgo de casa tengo que
volver a entrar a ella porque se me
olvida la mascarilla así que es
agradable estar libre de ese proceso de
pensamiento constantemente es agradable
poder vivir libre de nuevo en el resto
de europa italia también decidió
deshacerse de los cubrebocas en el
exterior tras el descenso de casos un
anuncio recibido como una bocanada de
aire fresco obviamente da una parte de
un lado sigue siendo necesaria la
cautela porque dejar todas las
restricciones de golpe sería un error
pero mientras nos mantengamos en
espacios abiertos dicen aglomeraciones
aplaudo esta medida
en francia la obligación de llevar
mascarilla en la calle se suprimió a
principios de febrero y el reino unido-
ya no se exige legalmente el uso de
mascarillas en interiores medidas que se
espera sean el comienzo de un regreso a
la normalidad en todo el continente